after a record-breaking 2020 wildfire
season
american firefighters are battling more
and bigger blazes this year
and it's taking a toll a lot of times
we're on the lines we're very stressed
there but we don't realize when we're
back home we haven't had a chance to
really process that
about 26 thousand firefighters are
battling more than 100 blazes in 14
states many of those fighting northern
california's dixie fire
the largest active blaze in the u.s live
and sleep in its dense smoke often
intense
but this isn't a typical you get to go
home sleep in your own bed kind of deal
it's a very
challenging and rewarding career but it
is also very strenuous
and tough job and it is not something
that everybody can do
and the people that do it really commit
themselves and their families to do it
with smoke sometimes grounding the
planes and helicopters that drop
water and flame retardant the men and
women on the ground
often have to go it alone driving
through
fire and battling the flames it does
take a special
kind of person who runs to the fire
you know then away and
you know those are the types of heroes
that we need
they can't save every town fires fueled
by high winds turned greenville into a
charred ghost town
overnight there are five thousand people
battling the dixie fire they come from
federal
state and local fire departments near
and far some work 24-hour shifts
and they live in this parking lot it's a
rugged lifestyle but the ones we've
talked to say
they have no complaints you're away from
your family for quite a few days
but and it's a lot of hard work
we love doing this so it's not really
it's something we love doing
the dixie fire has burned for four weeks
and is now only about
one-third contained first responders say
they expect to have it fully contained
by august 20th
when they can let it burn out and battle
the next blaze
in a fire season that can last through
november
john hendren al jazeera quincy
california